[Music]
hello from comic-con everybody I'm ash
Crossan and you may recognize the people
in this room
the cast of stranger things how's
everybody doing happy Holika you guys
congratulations on the Emmy nomination
thanks thank you
just as for barb is being served in the
form of an Emmy nomination for sure has
a reaction there would definitely be
justice served well we do have at least
two new comers coming
Sadie sink and April Montgomery yeah um
welcome how has it been mixing up with a
cast so far it's crazy and so excited
it's been like so much fun
just filming and know this is just the
beginning of press and stuff this is
really like my first time yeah with
everyone everyone's like I've been
waiting Pat answer a question because
I'm like and I've seen I mean I saw when
you guys were walking in you were all
hugging each other so you're obviously
getting along very great big Anna is all
an ass so what what can you tell me
about your character in the dynamic with
with the rest of the characters no Matt
I play Max and she is a big tomboy she's
really tough and it's been fun playing
her because I don't consider myself a
tomboy so and she um she moves from
California to Hawkins so that's how she
fits into season 2 it's how she mixes it
out and the first episode huh here yes
oh it's it no it's San Diego oh yeah
I know it's something saying we're all
learning stuff the first episode is
titled Mad Max so we're gonna meet you
at the gate huh good old Max is it
really well Noah will seems to be a big
focus of season 2 how is he handling his
I don't know what do we call it upside
down infection can't say much because
I'll have like my safe really what can
you tell me about eleven what time code
do we see her for the person yeah I mean
she's obviously back that's really you
know it's gonna be it's amazing and you
really dig into the life yes barb is
dead look at 11:00 in the back I think
she should have it like a horror show
the life of the lovin you know just like
on teal city 30 seconds there's
confessionals
that's the whole shot yeah my anger
[Music]
well you guys had to deal with a lot of
keeping secrecy for season one I'm sure
what did you learn between season one
and season two is there anything you
accidentally spoiled in season one what
I didn't know that um
the series was gonna get like picked up
for a second season I didn't really care
and so their friend my best friend was
like I was serious and I was like okay
so will cost up and I've got a sink and
like I just didn't like no oh yeah sure
like I was like sending I was like not
you know like two family members but
like not thinking that the show is and
then now you know they have what has bad
we were also like we didn't know like
what I didn't know we're confidential we
meant like I was like Shh yeah
confidential I remember I gave up the
demo gorgon and we'll coming back again
I'm gonna come out yet and I gave it up
as a and then games like
you